Briona is with us in Texas hey Briana
how are you hi Dave and Rachel I'm
amazing how are you both better than I
deserve how can we help so I really
admire you guys and I value your opinion
and I want you to know what your
thoughts are on this
so my husband and I are on baby step 2
currently we have 47,000 left to pay and
I work two jobs so I work a full-time
job at a credit union and then I work
weekends at a restaurant as a server and
I've been doing this for 13 years so
it's been a long road we moved here from
California about four years ago from the
Bay Area and when we were there the
income at the restaurant was to help us
survive but now we're in Austin and it's
a lot less expensive so that income has
gone towards debt so in March I got
furloughed from the restaurant and with
everything going on and it's been two
months and I've really enjoyed not
having to work seven days a week it's
been really nice having a Saturday I
feel like I have a normal life and
having a Saturday and Sunday being with
my husband being with my family so it's
time to go back my boss called me and
said hey I'm ready to put you on the
schedule and honestly I don't I don't
want to go back so what is your
household income not counting the
restaurant job 120,000 okay and how much
debt have you guys reduced in the last
year or two since we started FPU we
attend celebration church and we took up
to you in October so since October we've
paid off about 12,000 okay so you're on
a $24,000 a year schedule making 120
yeah kind of wimpy yeah you're kind of
bunch of stuff out of your life have you
I have but I guess not as much as I
should
I mean 120 minus 24,000 means you're
still spending $95,000 yeah did I miss
something okay no so I don't know where
it's going I mean how much is your house
payment
1900 we just got the house two years ago
so we this is before I knew about you so
you have 47,000 left see I think making
120 you could be done in a year
we cannot be double the rate what you've
been doing though okay and if I thought
that then I think you know then I think
well I've been waiting tables 13 years I
don't wanna do this anymore but I can do
it for one more year to get out of that
and then I could drop it or not I don't
know how much this of waiting tables add
to the budget
it's about Y is about two thousand a
month but and now with everything it's
going to be very different for a while
so I'm estimating it's going to be maybe
maybe about 200 a weekend 200 or 250 say
we'll just say 50% tables so we'll cut
it in half you know thousand dollars
yeah that's twelve thousand dollars a
year see twelve thousand dollars a year
doesn't solve this problem as much as
getting into your budget and cutting
some other stuff in your lifestyle I
would stay home and cut my lifestyle
like crazy okay that you've not done yet
if you want to quit I mean and then and
then as you get geared up you probably
could jump back in there if you wanted
to work for six months after you rest up
a little bit what do you think you guys
have kids I have two stepsons they're
older 15 and 25 okay okay yeah I was
gonna say your yeah your living
situation is always different with
little ones around yeah I mean cuz
here's the deal when it comes to getting
out of debt the deeper you sacrifice
your lifestyle and your time by working
extra the faster you're gonna get out of
debt so you guys need to just map this
out and say okay what could we do if we
went radical what option a is what if I
worked part-time and we cut our
lifestyle like crazy
how fast could we get out option B what
if I didn't work but we just cut the
lifestyle
option C what if we didn't cut the
lifestyle which and I just worked extra
like look at your options and go ahead
and map it out and I think you'll
probably be motivated to do option a of
maybe just doing both because you'll see
at the end game and it'll be faster than
what you guys are doing if you cut your
lifestyle too so just it's your it's
your willingness it's a personal choice
for you guys of you know what how deeply
you want to cut the lifestyle and the
time that you have at home by working
extra is
fast you're gonna get out now here's the
thing okay let's also acknowledge that
you've done a really good job you got a
great start you've learned brand new
habits yeah and you've been applying
them since October and you've made good
progress twelve thousand dollars of no
slouch but if you're listening to the
debt-free screams the people that call
in here making 120 you're gonna hear a
faster rate of debt reduction than then
twenty-four thousand a year on 120
thousand income when you hear the other
people doing the debt free screams and
that's that means that they're doing
something lifestyle cut that you aren't
so it's not to say you've done a
horrible job now this is what you were
overspending before now you're under
spending about twenty four thousand a
year that's really good
okay which actually was about the amount
of your waitress income yeah
and so you can't cut this unless you cut
the budget because you'll be in debt
forever and you may look at the job I
mean considering where we are right now
I know Texas are you guys I guess you
guys are opening restaurants obviously
cuz you're going back to where yeah but
is it capacity it's all kind of funky
right now anyway so you're not it's not
like yeah so that's something to be
considered too that it may you're gonna
have to figure out okay you know if I do
work it is gonna look different than it
was that it wasn't gonna work as many
hours for half the money it sounds like
to that's a possibility so you may not
want to do that right now yeah but you
can you cannot reduce your debt by the
exact amount of the waitress income then
the waitress income goes away that means
if you don't change something in the
budget you're not reducing debt at all
and so you've got to figure that part
out as a part of this equation I do hear
that you're tired of this but the only
way I can survive being tired of it is I
gotta be able to see that the light at
the end the tunnel and if I could look
over and go in one year I'm completely
done if I bust it I can bust it for a
year I can do anything for a year you
know I can do anything for six months I
can do anything for three months I mean
I can go crazy for a short period of
time to get a longer result to live like
no one else so that later I can live and
give like no one else I can you know no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
the Bible says but he yields a harvest
of
righteousness and so that you know it
doesn't feel good when you're doing it
but but I'm with you I would not do it
unless I could see that it was getting
me to my goal because that just that the
fatigue that goes with this sense of no
traction is unbearable yeah it's
terrible it's like living in a black
hole you're just like wandering around
with no direction